hey everybody welcome to live-streaming
with Jessie today we're gonna continue
on with what we've been doing the last
two streams and that's working on this
homepage
yesterday we we got some cards put in
like a masonry layout but we were having
some trouble getting some of the cards
to take up the full width of the columns
that we wanted them to be in so I
actually found a fix for that that was
really simple and I don't know I'm gonna
lie didn't think of it yesterday or you
know maybe one of you thought of it were
trying to tell me in the chat and I just
was not getting it but I'm gonna show
you what that fixes and then we're gonna
get started and and finished this page
and it was so simple I just I'm almost
embarrassed now how simple it was but
let me get started oh there's a lot in
the live chat already okay there were
some questions about whether or not
beginners can watch this stream I would
say beginners will probably get
something out of this stream they may
not understand everything some streams
are more beginner friendly than others
this stream maybe it's like middle of
the road the the whole point of me doing
these videos when I first thought
thought up you know the idea of doing
these was just to see what it's like for
me to do my job as a front-end developer
and especially to help those people who
are beginners or maybe people who are
freelance and always work alone I know I
I still don't know what it's like for
developers you know who like work on a
team at a big company you know what
their day-in day-out job is like so I
thought I'd be cool people to see that
but not just seeing me but specifically
see me mess up and how I work
that and I thought maybe it would give
beginners more confidence that you know
seeing somebody who's getting paid to do
this mess up so much maybe they would
think hey like I'm way better than this
guy I definitely can get it tough
so anyway because of that I think
beginners could get something from any
of these shows but if you're looking for
a tutorial this is not the right stream
there are a lot of other great tutorials
on the free code camp Channel and on
other channels on YouTube but you
sometimes it's somewhat like a tutorial
but I I there's no way I could in good
conscience call this a tutorial we just
we mess up way too much and it's not
really that structured so anyway if you
are a beginner and you're watching feel
free to stick around love to have you
here and feel free to ask questions I
don't answer questions right away
I split it up into Pomodoro sessions or
25-minute periods of coding and then I'd
do five minutes of question-and-answer
and then at the very end if there's any
questions left over I get to all those
questions so just be patient if you ask
a question occasionally someone will ask
a question and they'll keep asking it
over and over and wondering if I'm going
to answer their question well I don't
even see it because I'm doing the coding
so just be patient I'll get to it
let's see Michael McCrea says it's
usually tutorial for you Jesse that's it
that's right
these videos are a tutorial for me
because you all helped me out so much I
learned how I should say truth yeah
Irish it has contributed significantly
to my learning into my project so yeah
glad you're here today are you sure I
miss you yesterday I was trying to do it
a little bit earlier so you wouldn't
have to stay up so late okay all right
one more thing before we start
I made a video and I I posted it on my
youtube channel so there's a link to
that I think in the description to this
video so this is the free code camp
channel I do most of my live streams
here but if I come out with videos on
other topics or a tutorial I put that on
my own personal channel so check that
out if you want the video is on getting
motivated after the holidays so it's
just I I think I mentioned this
yesterday to you all but just a really
short it's like three minutes of how I
got through my sluggishness after the
holidays and getting back into it so
maybe it'll help somebody else out if
you're trying to get back in the you
know in decoding after taking a little
break okay let's see someone asks about
languages frameworks we're using mostly
JavaScript and react how Michael said up
there there's no bird in the background
here my I had I actually went and
consulted I did some consulting work and
so I just came in from outside and
there's snow everywhere so the snow is
melting on the bottom of my shoes and
it's my shoes are squeaking on the floor
as I kind of shift it out in my chair so
I apologize for the weird sound that's
just the squeaking of my shoes
all right so that's all let me let me
show you are the screen there we go okay
so here's what we've got so far so not a
whole lot also I forgot to push the
changes to the github repo from
yesterday so I apologize to anyone who
tried to check out the code it wasn't up
to date I pushed them this morning so it
is up to date now so you can see we have
these cart these three cards here were
really thin now they're they're taking
up the full width like they should we
still need to get this gutter sorted out
and we'll do that probably the first
thing we work on but I want to show you
how I did this so all I added to each
one of these grid items here not to the
Container grid which I think we removed
anyway but today these great items that
we were putting that we wanted to take
up a certain amount of space so full
width quarter with things like that we
added this grid item fix class and I'll
show you what it was really easy grid
item fix gives it a width of 100% that's
it so if you I don't know if you all
remember from yesterday when we checked
in dev tools on the classes that were
being applied to that that div it was
applying a max width based on you know
what was supposed to be so if we wanted
it to be fourth of the screen it was
saying max width 25% but it had no width
property so all I did was say okay well
let's put with 100% it'll still be
limited by that max width property right
and that's it worth so it's a simple fix
now it's not universe right so if we
wanted to use this grid
system on other pages we would have to
make sure we keep carrying that over so
depending on what we want to do with it
we may want to come up with a different
way to implement this kind of like
globally but for right now this works
fine for what we're gonna be doing today
so ended up being just very simple and
yeah sometimes that happens you know
sometimes you gotta sleep on it and it's
it worked out okay
let's see let me start this Pomodoro
timer and let's get that this gutter
worked out to about you know the way
that we want it so I do want to work
within material UI here's the docks so
if you want to follow on with the
documentation it's material - UI
- next comm and actually I'm just gonna
paste this in right now so I can just go
right to it and you know what let me
sorry
let me run and rock as well I forgot to
do that yesterday
I think I have it up here I do
nope
I think we're running this on for 3,000
yep we are alright so I'm gonna have a
link for you all to view this on your
machine as well the link doesn't wasn't
working huh that's crazy
it's the same length
okay I don't know why the link isn't
working
but that that's exactly the that's
really weird all right so maybe it is
working for some people I mean if you go
to the main site and navigate to there
hopefully it will now it works okay
all right seems like it's working now
maybe it's YouTube redirects oh okay all
right so here's what I want to check out
see if there is some sort of gutter kind
of built into the API maybe space space
between I haven't components that
contain anything five minutes
okay this you can only use this on the
container component and we got rid of
our container component so that may not
work
all right maybe we'll all right so I
don't think we can put the container
grid back no that's not the right one
yeah we did get rid of it down here I
don't think we're gonna be able to put
the container back without messing
things up so let's try this see if it
works let's just throw margin on this
element we'll just give it this goes 16
pixels for now so just 16 pixels all
around and let's see if this actually
works I'm skeptical that this will work
well with what we have going on huh Wow
not bad okay but one thing it did do is
it messed up our our column see so move
this over so if we change it to padding
maybe maybe it will have better results
there we go okay so actually this is a
really good kind of beginners lesson
with CSS so the reason why it didn't
work with margin but it does work with
padding is because actually let me open
up dev tools it'll be easier to explain
this with with this here okay so you can
see this this displays an element and
I'm I'm actually going to get the card
here so it's displaying okay so this is
actually what we just did we just added
a padding of 16 on to this so what it
does here when it calculates the width
of this item any padding is actually
counted
as the item with so when we're saying
elsewhere that we only want this this
container to take up 50% of this space
it's going to include the padding in
there when we put it as margin it
doesn't include margin in the width as
the width of the container so it was
saying okay we're gonna have this take
up just this component alone plus
whatever padding we had which happened
to me nothing but we're gonna take all
this and make this the full 50% width
but then when you add the margin in it
ends up being a little bit more so maybe
52 percent with right so then if we add
it up all the three elements which
should be 25 25 and 50% we ended up
instead of getting 100% which we should
have we would end up getting something
like I don't know 110 percent that's why
this other one got pushed down to here
because we gone over the percentage
right so really you know there's it's
not always obvious on when's the right
time to use margin and when's the right
time to use padding but in this case
it's clear padding is giving us what we
want here and margin did not there's
price of other cases we can think of
where you want to use one over the other
for sure and there are some cases where
you could use one or the other and it
won't really make a difference
Jony eight says is that still the case
in border-box
that's a good point let's let's mess
around a little bit with that just you
know since we started let's switch this
and use okay so it is it's already using
border box let's have it use content box
this is going to
and we'll use content box and then we'll
switch the margin we'll switch this to a
margin okay so now this is using margin
and they're also using content box so
let's move this back to border box and
see what happens all right so we're
getting this and I'm just confirming
that this is we're actually getting the
behavior we didn't want let's see if it
changes with content bugs okay it isn't
changing with content bugs and let's see
what happens if we keep content box with
our padding and let's switch it up okay
all right that's where the difference is
all right so just to verify before I
explain this because I don't explain the
wrong wrong thing I'm gonna switch this
back to border and there we go okay
so let me go back to here so we could
see so here's what happens when we use
border box which border box is usually
the default correct I'm I'm almost
positive that normally it's most sites I
work on his border box so a border box
works normally as I explained before
when you switch to content box then what
happens is the the actual width of the
content is taken as the width right
padding then acts like margin did in our
first example so now the padding is
actually in addition so the full 50% in
the case of this code
dear the full 50% is taking up just by
this part this content and then in
addition to that there is padding and
that is gonna add you know 52 percent or
something right it's gonna be 52 percent
somewhere around there so if you're
still having trouble you know with
something like this make sure you check
your box sizing as well I tend to stick
with border box for pretty much
everything I rarely even think about
this it's not it's not an issue normally
but thanks for bringing that up Johnny
that definitely could have been
confusing if someone was working with
something that was set to content box
instead of border box all right so let
me know if you all appreciate some of
those that little kind of side side bar
there to explain things I'll try to do
that more if if you think it's helpful
if you'd rather me just get to the point
and start coding that that's cool too
Wow
my network I apologize if the video
quality was bad I just glanced at my
network and it was terrible it seems
like it's back now at normal so
let's see I just wanna make sure I did
answer that question adequately
okay Johnny says thank you for
explaining that it's just like you Arjun
yeah yes
okay cool so let's let's move on then
well let's let's make sure this width is
actually what we want I I think that was
okay oh and we still we need to make
sure we we have our items take up the
proper space on smaller screens
now that's interesting it shifts over
this way I would think that it would
shift it would go this way from left to
right it's good to know for a layout
though all right
actually Harsha's saying
use materialized you're using many
selectors on those divs the necessary
okay so hardship thinks we should just
use the materialized column classes okay
so hard [ __ ]
prefers using the materialized grid
maybe we'll switch to that I'm not gonna
switch to it on the stream right now
because it's mostly just copy and paste
way but that might not be a bad idea to
switch to we already talked about
yesterday wolf why we might switch to
that so I'm still open to that there was
just a part of me that really wanted to
see if I could get this to work and and
we have a a solution so we'll see if the
solution continues to work if we run
into too many bugs we'll see how that
how leg goes okay so we do have extra
small/small actually we we already have
we already have the right the right
columns on here so that it should be
full width let's see what's going on
there so we may have found our first bug
oh there we go now it is working it was
just set to extra small so I think
yeah let's let's set this a bit
differently yeah so let's see for a
small screens right now we have small I
mean okay for all our smalls where we
have it set to three we're gonna change
things up a bit
and we're gonna go let's let's try first
let's try six for small and then medium
I assume medium is MD we'll find out in
a second if that works for mediums then
we'll go with our three with our quarter
so that should be a nicer transition on
small screens and
okay
I made sure to see how this how this
works okay so here's our large screen
it's like normal see what break point is
ok so around 930 pixels somewhere on
there 9 950 we have our small break
point and that's when it goes down to 2
now we go down to 1 okay so it looks
like it's still these are still too thin
even on our medium size so I think we're
gonna have to we're gonna we're gonna
have to bump that up another screen size
another screen width so let's take our
mediums we'll take our mediums and
change them to large and I think that'll
work
okay
so now we should get there we go we get
to split a lot earlier we get it up
there around 1200 pixels and that that's
nicer now we don't have content
extending out over that card so these
are still you know a bit narrow here
once you get down to 1200 pixels but you
know we'll see what happens with the
with the content when we get real
content in there then I think we can do
more adjustments for now that's only
adjust when I really want to do no sense
and really you know getting too detailed
with this when we're still just kind of
experimenting okay is everybody cool was
that it was that somewhat
straightforward let me know in the live
chat I'll check back in a minute and see
if anyone needs me to explain that a bit
more
and see
all right cool so let's add a few more
cards in I definitely want to add in a
card for video and yeah I'm not sure if
I want to keep this cards are right with
the image and then like text potentially
down here but it might not be a bad idea
to just have one you know just with an
image in it maybe we could try one out
with an image and a text overlay that
might not be a bad idea okay
alright let's try that out
so let's grab down here we're only using
up on the large you're really using up
25% because we didn't put another card
down here so let's grab another card
actually let's grab this wow that's too
much I don't want to get that all that
let's grab this card here and I'm gonna
put another one right in here on top of
this and let's make this let's take away
this large here so this is going to end
up being 50% of the screen for most
screen sizes and for the card content
this is what I want to do I I don't
think I saw anything specifically for a
video let me see where we have our image
so we have card media let's check out
the API for the card media and see if we
can't add a video if not then we'll just
do our thing the only I was worried
about is there's padding built in here
to this card content
I think there's padding built in the
card content so we would want our video
to go completely like end-to-end let's
see where's my okay here it is
so let's check out our cards API and
card frog Wow
it seriously it that's all we have we
can also just use paper to make kind of
our own video component if we want to I
was just kind of hoping that they
already had something built-in to the
cards but it won't be too much extra
work if they don't okay so here's our
media okay so it's just showing an image
our media API yes
okay so it looks like we can do
something with with video and the shoes
for you
that's it back right
yeah
all right so I all right it's not as
straightforward as I thought let me
check the live chat and see if anybody
is reading this kind of differently than
me it seems like from from this part it
says in that you know a video would be
possible to put in here but I don't know
it's it's not 100% clear to me let's see
ok hard [ __ ] says if you set the
component as video and the source to
video but this will give you html5
player ok we'll probably want to end up
using the YouTube player so maybe it'll
be better if ok harsh it says you can't
add the iframe yeah ok maybe we'll try
it out with a YouTube embed ok cool
so let me grab the YouTube embed code I
have I have the video that I just did up
here so let's grab the code on my other
screen it's got the code from here
so you don't want to share we want to
embed
okay
all right so let's see how we're gonna
do this I should said shameless plug
yellow yeah yes it's by the way check
out my video um alright which one are we
just coffee
I should have coffee the one that had
card media was I thinking alright
[Music]
Media and we gonna do
what was that source
see so do we put so I keep flying back
and forth hear me do I need to put
source iframe here or what I generally
like the documentation they have for
this but this is a little big for me
maybe I'm just not getting it maybe it's
more obvious to you all
whoa that's not what I wanted to do what
else do we need to put in an image a
shrinkies a Dom element or a component
okay let's do
two years working on it okay so I guess
within component that's where I would
put this
is it gonna let me just in suscribe
let's see
oh okay so hard should say in the source
put the URL in the component put the
iframe all right Thank You hard [ __ ]
so let me let me just paste this in here
quickly so I can grab the source
and now I will say iframe
[Music]
okay
see what we get uh-oh I'm not bad it's
not great but it's not bad so we need we
need that is something right yeah I
think it says the props will useful to
extend the style applied to components
okay
alright let's see how this this would
look
but there's something it's going off the
page because I just changed it in dev
tools and I didn't give see what if I
adjust it see now the masonry has a
chance to lay it out properly but yeah
cool play right in there all right not
bad it still has some weird stuff going
on around the edges some space down here
that we don't want so I need some work
but it's not it's mostly what we want
okay all right let's see my timer went
off let's do a short break here and let
me go to the live chat
[Music]
okay goog GI o or GI so correct me if
I'm pronouncing that wrong but gog asks
have a question float vs. inline-block
using floats is not too old comparing to
the inline-block same can be achieved
with inline-block as using floats but
less code no need of clear fixes thanks
yeah so is there are a lot of different
ways to position things in CSS so yeah
some things are considered older to use
than others I'm of the opinion generally
that if it works it works right it's
fine to use the issue gets in some cases
what about performance you know does it
cut down on on your speed most sites
don't need to worry about it that much
you know but some sites you know even
shaving milliseconds is is important
right so you generally do want to know
about what the best ways are to use and
some of the newer ways to do things
instead of using floats or inline block
is to use flexbox we're now the new CSS
grid and so it's good to know flexbox
and grid for instance you know if you're
gonna do anything with react native all
the positioning is through flexbox right
so it would be a good idea to just you
know start learning that and start
positioning with that but if you're not
good with that kind of stuff yet and you
got to do something then you know the
older ways will work it's it's okay but
as kind of people start using flexbox
and grid more and more it's going to be
harder to understand what's going on and
other projects if you're still kind of
using the older stuff off the top of my
head I don't really know
with the differences in terms of you
know speed right but that would be what
I would look at when I would if I was
really trying to decide okay which one's
best which one I need to use if it was
going to be a big deal I would check
that out also you had mentioned you
could use less code with one or the
other no need for clear fixes that that
is another thing to take into
consideration how difficult is it to
implement one versus the other
can you save lines of code so anyway
hopefully that kind of answered your
question a bit but I mean if you're
using something that out that is
considered somewhat older you hear that
don't feel too bad about it right I mean
you know to build stuff we're all doing
things the best way we know how the idea
is that we keep learning things but you
can't learn all the new stuff all at
once right you just keep adding on every
project you try to learn some different
and use newer stuff right so you may
only learn one new thing on the next
project but you know eventually you know
you'll keep up and you'll keep learning
new things let's see
Vinnie ak asked how did you MIT how did
you fix image with in masonry I just
added I'll show you right now I just
added to our grid items I just added a
width of 100% and then I added some
padding one on top of that that was all
it took it ended up being so simple
let's see Harshit says I consider this
doing work to achieve nothing you are a
programmer use the shortest and bug-free
way possible I'm telling you this with
my previous experience in the bulletin
project okay so you're talking to honey
that you're talking about using
the grid system that comes with masonry
or I'm sorry Latino UI versus just using
the column classes from materialize
that's a good point I do remember that
that it ended up being a real pain to
try to get that to work with that
bulletin project so we may end up
switching to that then so I'm gonna have
to take a look I'll take a look at the
bulletin project to see how it was done
there I am way more comfortable with the
materialized column classes really so it
will be easier for me in the long run to
just use materialized so but anyway like
I said I'm not gonna switch it right now
on the stream I think we're still we are
still doing some valuable stuff because
we've explained like we got to explain
all about padding and margins and stuff
right and to be honest with you the
purpose of what we're doing right now
and in heart should I explain this
yesterday so you might not have caught
it already I'm just trying to get my
boss something to look at so it's
intended now it's intended that
everything's gonna be refactored
significantly once we decide on
something so everything we're doing
right now may end up getting scrapped
and we don't use any of it okay so at
this point that's why it may not
actually be worth it for me to switch to
materialise called classes right now
because we may not even use this at all
hopefully I'm sure this to my boss soon
get some feedback and then we'll know at
that point that's probably the better
time to make the decision but at least
we have you know I and and I know you
already know cuz you try them both but
now you know we have got along the
stream a nice comparison of you know you
can go back and watch the old stream see
how we did it with the column classes
for materialized and now we could see
how we deal with the grid I don't know
you know how I am I always like to try
two different ways and see which one
works out can't always do that
sometimes there's just not enough time
but in this case I think it's worthwhile
the process of going through it I think
is worthwhile it may take a little
longer but I usually learn a lot in the
process so let me my five-minute timer
did go off I spent a lot of time on just
a few questions sorry I still have a
call from when I was sick over the break
let's see
so I'm trying to figure out where I just
left off in the live chat so I can go
right back to it after the Mex break
1:28 okay
oh yeah all right I'm gonna go off-topic
for just a second like I have this bag
of Sour neon gummy worms like sitting
right next to me I just want to eat him
so bad I don't want to be rude and be
like chewing right when I'm trying to do
this video so it's taking a lot of
willpower for me not I'm just gonna
throw him in a drawer I can't look at
him anymore
they had him on sale when I went to the
store earlier this week and I just I
wanted them out and now they're like I'm
addicted to these gummy worms I'm sure
my dentist loves that okay all right so
let's do one more moment of a session we
do at least one more and so what we're
gonna do
oh I'm gonna leave this like this for
now like I said since I'm just gonna
show my boss how this looks it doesn't
have to be perfect so I'm okay with this
looking a little off I would never want
to actually launch a site with it
looking like that but I think it's fine
just just to give them an idea but it's
actually this is really throwing me off
that things are getting put in place
like this let's see
and it's just
okay
maybe it's an option within masonry as
to whether things get displayed right to
left or left to right off look into that
I'm okay with it now but eventually I'm
thinking my boss will probably want to
be able to have more control over thing
where things are so I'll look into the
options I know you can do there's a lot
of options if you use just the
straight-up JavaScript plug-in I'm
assuming that at least some of those
options can be used with the react
component version of masonry so we'll
look into that later if we end up going
with this all right what did I say I
needed oh let's do a card that has just
an image and we get rid of this
yeah let's actually just get rid of this
right now this is hype ah graphy yeah
yeah card action it's typography we'll
get rid of that I just want to give kind
of an assortment of potential options
for my boss to look at okay cool so this
is just a straight image card
I'm gonna copy this and just put a
different title in here in different
names just maybe like latest posts like
latest blog post or something and then
what do we do another one maybe it'll
say like oh actually let's do one let's
do a card it's like a spotlight right
spotlight on a faculty member or on a
student or maybe on a graduate already
we'll throw some of those in there as
well so I think for our purposes now we
may just be able to modify what we're
doing here for a lot of that alright but
first let's get this this grid it's so
this component is starting to get huge
and it's just like it just doesn't feel
right but it's gonna have to be like
this for now okay okay so we're gonna
head this one and let's change events to
[Music]
latest posts I think that's yeah that'll
be what we need oops let me define them
into some multiple cursors
oh I do not work and
there you go
all right let's check it out it should
work we just done it but just to verify
ok cool latest pose pose one two three
four we may want to show this with some
more text so let's throw that in one
thing that we aren't having that I
wanted to avoid is we still are having
some space which I guess we really we
can't avoid that if we're gonna have so
many different widths and Heights
there's gonna be some space so yeah I
just there's not there's not really a
way to avoid all the space so we're
gonna have to live with that or yeah I
mean I just don't see how how I could
get around that without really being
strict about card Heights oh well it's
fine for now it is really is gonna
depend on the screen as well so here we
you know that it's changed obviously on
a small smaller screen we're gonna have
right we have none here and for sure
we're gonna have none when it's all
stacked like this okay
let's see if I can add some some more
text on here see if this will work for
us we have what is this so list item
list item text primary so since there's
already a primary let's just try
secondary and see if that works if this
doesn't work I'll look it up in the
documentation
yeah hey it works why there we go
okay so cool we have some secondary
texts awesome tool that's good I know my
boss will want to see that because he
definitely won't want just titles of
stuff so so that's good
this font size is way too small so we'll
probably have to work on the font size
at some point but for now this is okay
suppose okay let's work on a card that's
just going to have let's say like an
image and someone's name maybe their
title and then some some info about them
I just saw coding and caffeine said
hello everyone I'm here for the coffee I
didn't have any coffee today I really I
did have some G fuel I chug some right
before the stream so G fuel if you're
watching give me a sponsorship
anyway but also whoever Kroger made
those gummy worms and sold them so I
could get a sponsorship from Kroger if
anybody's got connections right I've
using opinions on my own and they do not
reflect those a freak okay
all right it's the first thing I want to
try to do is just grab this great
component and let's copy it and then
remove some of these lists let's remove
all but one of these list items okay I
don't think this is gonna work cuz it'll
be too small yeah it's too small but
let's see if we can change some of the
options here so we're we AG was our list
okay this what we had
let's check out the API for list item
and let's check it out for list item
avatar as well and let's see this is
interesting list item we have a list
item text as well okay so we may have
some other options for how to how to
create this
let's see what we have the avatar is not
much
seized
you
okay that doesn't look like anything
that helpful for what I wanted to do
which I guess I haven't explained I just
want this to be bigger so let's uh I'm
gonna actually I'm gonna leave this
let's make this bigger
this is checkout in dev tools first just
to see what we may want in terms of size
yeah so I was assuming that this was set
to 100% which it is for the image so we
need to do then is change our width and
height for this avatar div so let's go
with
one hundred one hundred and see what
that gives us
okay I want it to be bigger for the
feature so let's try two hundred and two
hundred okay that's not bad just for
this and then we'll also want to
increase this font size
all right we'll just set that for that
right now okay
so list item avatar we're gonna make a
class for this because we're gonna have
more than one of these so give it a
class name of habits
which are
Avatara big that's that's pretty
straightforward and then this list item
text we're gonna give that a class name
as well
classes let's talk about let's say
list.txt big
oh yeah one of the hardest parts about
doing this live is just coming up with
names
it's hard enough coming up with names
for your stuff but like when you're
right on the spot
it is hard who's that hey Brian sighs
was in here Brian works in the office
right next to me he's a developer - you
want one of these gummy worms right come
in and get one if you own one you want
to be on the show just knock on the door
I'll open it okay you see how much time
I have I do want to okay cool I have
enough time to get this done all right
so let's go back up here to where we're
adding in our CSS so I think we went
over this yesterday but if you didn't if
you weren't with us yesterday notice
this is a normal CSS this is actually a
JavaScript object so some of it looks
familiar some of it doesn't we are camel
casing all of our class names and we're
using you normally with CSS or you type
it like this and then we have our
semicolons but we're using commas now
like a JavaScript object okay so this is
one of the ways we can do it within a
react component we'll use some some
different ways as the string continues
and in previous streams we've used some
different ways but this what we're using
right now so what did I say avatar big
happen to our big and we wanted to make
the width what do we say 200 oops
pixels and the height
200 pixels whoops
type 102 and now let's do the item list
item text big and then we're gonna say
font size font size we got a 34
yeah 34 pixels there we go okay let's
see if this works
it should only apply to that last one
yep
all right cool awesome all right so
let's say you know what I'm gonna put
this one end because this is probably
not going to make it on the actual site
so I'm just gonna put this one in for
fun
and let me grab we got a picture
alright let's see this works
and primate X
so this
yes all right cool this is my boss
Michael just said this will make it on
this final site so I'll do it for fun
equals famous last words one time I made
a whole site and everything was really
sarcastic like the images were all funny
and the captions and all the images were
all sarcastic and all the text was and
some of it actually I had to change it
so it wasn't so sarcastic but some of it
did make it on the final site but it was
just really fun to show everybody who
was testing the site maybe this will be
an easter egg on the site somewhere I
gotta put some sort of Easter Egg in it
like if you open dev tools like there'll
be something in the console and you know
something that most people won't see
okay let's see what I owe him on time
but anyway I actually I was thinking
that this list wouldn't work but it
really wasn't hard to adjust so this is
not bad so we would have features we're
not gonna feature staff member all the
staff members are like in the background
right the student and the faculty or the
stars of the show but we would probably
have a faculty member that we would
feature and a student and probably a
graduate as well and those would
probably change so that there would
either be arrows so that you could flip
through them or every time you loaded
the page it would change and we'd have
it some something set up so that maybe
like every day it changed you know sorry
somehow we'd be able to show show more
of them Michael said he does have a good
beard yet yeah his beer is actually
shorter than normal in this picture I
think this is an older picture I tried
to find a better
but is this like the only one that came
up on a Google search there's a lot of
people named Thomas crow so I didn't
realize food I mean I scrolled down for
like three seconds and I didn't see any
other pictures anyway all right so let's
see let's add in ladies pose pose let's
add in one more of this style and we'll
call it news and let's add in two or
three more of these style things and
then we'll see how it plays out maybe
we'll put in like another video on
another image one another one of these
to be honest with you that's really kind
of boring let's see I am on time because
we're not doing anything new we're just
gonna lay out some some things so I
guess I could just copy and paste a few
just so we can get an idea I don't know
that it's worth it to do it all on the
stream though oh you're gonna grab the
image one and if I want to know a list
let's grab another list see this will be
so nice when these are all separated out
into their own components it'll make it
so much shorter this is starting to get
a little out of hand list and let's grab
the
the video and the image one
see I can't even find what I want
anymore all right here's a video on
just throw one of these in here and just
one more I'll find an image and I'll
throw it in there area but you can see
hopefully like even if you're not that
familiar to react you can start to see
already which pieces of this page would
be good to separate out into their own
components and make them more reusable
like imagine if we could condense all
this down into just one line that's
easily readable you know and it would
say image image card or something like
that and we just be able to pass in a
few a few props a few things that we
would wanted to have and it would it
would shorten this up significantly
all right so I'm gonna say that and
let's just whoa what did I do okay
whoops looks like I grabbed the end of a
masonry tag did I wait a second yeah I
added the masonry say in the wrong place
there we go
and I'm assuming then I have another tag
in the wrong place somewhere as well
this is that where it needs to go whoops
so let's see where the other air is the
div seat okay oh hey cool did it work
yeah it works oh we forgot to actually
add a height in it for this
mm not perfect but we can see what would
what I need to make sure of is maybe
giving more thought to like what we have
lined up next to each other so you know
making sure that we we always are
equaling a hundred percent with with all
them you know each section we equal 100%
so that we don't have you know a lot of
gaps here but otherwise this should give
my boss I know this does to me this
looks terrible right now all right but
this should just give my boss something
to look at so that in his mind he can
say all cool like we could definitely
use that or put that there you know it
it really helps I mean you all probably
have the same experience but sometimes
it really helps to be able to see
something with some content in there to
really convey like what you're thinking
you know I could sketch something on a
piece of paper or just explain something
but it doesn't click with other people
you know you just don't get it until
they can see it like this so that's why
I do things like this and I think it's
really helpful at first just spend a
little bit of time build this out even
if we know that most of it might not
make it into the final site you end up
saving a lot of time in the long run if
you don't do something like this either
building it out as a site or using not
only like sketch or Photoshop or
something then you could end up doing a
lot of work and then finding out way too
late that the client or your boss or
whoever wants it different right so
better to waste a little bit of work at
the beginning than to have to redo
everything at the end all right so my
timer did go off so I'm gonna go back
and try to answer as much as I can
and let's see what time it is oh yeah
definitely I'm gonna answer all the
questions it doesn't matter how long it
takes
and let's 28th okay let me scroll up
okay a hearse that says will you be
making a pull request using materialized
Oh
Hardison says we'll be making a portable
crushed use materialized if I get time
I'm busy right now it is
alright cool hard [ __ ] totally
understand if you're busy you've been a
great help and I really appreciate all
the work you do so do not feel obligated
at all to do anything if you have time
and you want to do it that's awesome you
know otherwise I could I could try to do
it at some point or someone else could
take a shot at it if anybody wants to
check out what harsh it did with masonry
and materialized in the bulletin project
and then try to apply that to this
project but anyway you know I always
appreciate your work on this but if
you're busy you know get done which you
need to get done for school or for you
know whatever else you're working on
okay
okay John Hanson says iframe is a bit
tricky I found in react as it's
difficult for me to figure out if
mounted or any onload listener as it
would make sense to have an Network
offline or error image placeholder okay
yeah I've never I haven't worked that
much with iframes in react either I
guess we will know how it will work more
with them and I actually need to change
I don't know if who remembers working on
project 1 that catechetical Institute
site but on the home page there's this
really large video and we were using JW
player to embed that but it's not
working after I upgraded all the
packages we got so recently we tried to
to upgrade everything to the latest
version and everything worked out fine
seemingly except the video so I had no
luck working on it for way longer than I
should have and I think we're just gonna
switch it up and use YouTube which is
what I want to do originally months ago
but anyway we're gonna use YouTube now I
think and so I'll be dealing with
YouTube embeds and react on that project
as well
Josh Modine says hello hey hey Josh
how's it going thanks for joining us
haha world said in your motivation video
you start with it's a little after New
Year its July I know it's tough i yeah
if you haven't seen the video about
getting motivated it's on my channel
check it out if you like it's only like
three minutes but I did mess up right
off the beginning I I said that it was
July it's obviously not July recorded
the video yesterday it's January
I corrected myself right after yeah I
can't believe I said July
okay
Oh Michaels says by the way Jessie
thanks for the words yesterday when I
was at the hospital oh yeah no problem I
hope everything's all right
- so I understand if you want to talk
about it on the live stream or anything
like that but I just want to let you
know that everything's cool and you know
whatever whatever's going on is is
getting handled properly with the
doctors and everything
Harshit was getting a ton of questions
about his sleeping routine so these for
his timezone these streams are on you
know very late
he's clarified for everyone for the
record he sleeps about six hours so from
2 to 8 so it's 2 a.m. to 8 a.m. and 1:00
to 2:30 during the day so it's an
adequate amount of sleep yeah that's
like you know what is that 7 and a half
hours yeah almost 8 hours I went through
periods when I was a teenager where I
like would not sleep very much at all
and just stay up and hang out with my
friends which is way less productive
than coding hard [ __ ] is actually doing
some cool stuff with coding yeah so I
understand then I went through periods
where I slept all the time
michael says that iframe above your head
is kind of freaky
are you talking about this iframe or is
this a joke about the video I don't know
Harshit says Jessie this will all be
fixed if you materialize as it uses
flexbox with well-defined
widths okay Vinnie Vinnie axis fixing
image with was such a problem yesterday
yeah I know was it was such a problem
and it was so easy to fix
John Henson says LOL neon worms just
don't eat too many though you'll find
you won't need to turn the light on in
the bathroom we needed to go yeah I did
the neon the the gummy worm things here
definitely are probably not that healthy
let's see if I eat nine of these worms
it's 140 calories and 24 grams of sugar
but it has 2 grams of protein so that's
definitely gonna help me in the gym
right so I if I ate this whole bag that
would be 10 grams of protein I mean you
can't beat that right I should
definitely one of these before I work
out every day I'm not a doctor and
nutritionist so don't take any of my
advice
okay he says actually
spar wheel says what is the average time
you have to complete a website for a
client I don't know it really varies a
lot the last time I did a website for a
client it was like a year or something
crazy it was can usually what happened
this is what happened with a client
normally at first they want a website
like as soon as possible right
they're like you can stay up for three
days straight and give me this website
but then what happens you say okay fine
I can do the website I can do it by this
day but I need this content and then
when it's on them to produce content
give to you then it keeps pushing back
the date right so it always just takes a
long time it seems like when I get
clients because of that so I made sure I
put my contract that all the dates that
I have where I'm gonna complete things
by a certain date are all dependent on
when I get the material so if they're
late by a day my deadline gets pushed
back a day right so I'm not on one of my
previous projects things got pushed back
like I think the site was gonna be
completing like two months and end up
taking almost a year because I didn't
have the the materials and during that
period that was when my wife had a baby
and had a ton of problems and had to
have surgeries and things so the client
also like basically let me put the
project on hold during that time period
so I can take care of her and the kids
which was really awesome and very nice
of them but then also a lot of it the
time was because we're still waiting on
on content and things so I don't even
know that I could give an average at
this point it's just totally it just
really really depends on whether or not
the material is ready for the client I
mean in terms of what I could do and
that I mean it would have to be a large
site for me not to be able to do it
and you know like two months assuming I
could really dedicate hours every day to
it
I mean I'm talking like normal stuff you
need for small businesses and stuff
right
it should never take longer than that
for me to do it if they wanted something
like it's a really special maybe longer
I don't know I would I don't know if I
per for a longer a shorter time if it's
shorter than its kind of cool because
you get to work on new things but then
you have to worry about billing and
contracts more often but if you get like
a big client where you're working on it
for months you only have to deal with
the contract stuff once and the billing
well maybe once I would usually make
them pay some upfront and maybe some
like in the middle of project two but
and then you have guaranteed income
anyway that was a really long answer for
a simple question and I didn't answer
the question so I'm sorry about that but
maybe it gave a little insight in into
what things are like at least for me
when I do freelance work okay what sighs
okay John Hanson saying that you you can
change the direction so where I was
saying I wanted it to go left to right
and set it right to left so so we
definitely can't change that so I'll be
working on that maybe today or all
today's I was gonna say tomorrow with
tomorrow Saturday so it won't work on a
Saturday
Michael Creole says it might be only one
who seeing the iframe clipped vertically
yeah yeah that it's it is cliff
okay hard [ __ ] said he had to go at some
point but then he came back alright
can you set a grid the the fill in the
cards yeah maybe there's something that
I could do remember I didn't want a
bunch of whitespace in the cards though
I just have to think see like what would
look better to have some white space in
the card or to have this gap here it may
honestly look better to have white space
in a card I mean I think we've done
everything we can to eliminate most of
that but even so when we have gaps like
this I can't just fill that in with this
card the image would be all distorted so
I have to think more about that
Aleksey s are you using material UI yes
I am using material UI I've added in a
JavaScript plug-in called masonry and
I've used the react masonry component
package to bring that in so that's
what's kind of doing all this layout
with these cards but it is using
material UI as well on a site
t's AG says is asked is it a good idea
to restart from challenge one if it's
been a while since I've coded yeah it's
not bad if it's been a long time and you
really don't remember a lot then you
could start with challenge one again
you'd probably like go really fast
through some of them I would check that
if you find yourself going to challenge
one and like remembering everything then
maybe skip ahead so start with one see
how it goes if you don't remember a lot
of it then just keep going
if you do remember a lot then skip skip
ahead that's what I usually do if I like
quit a tutorial in the middle and then
don't come back to it for a while I
usually start over
tea Zach says does anyone have a few
pages of code for a website home page or
something similar I could look at for
reference tea Zach check out my github
profile and also the fu s Markham
organization on github we do have some
well we have a lot of different websites
so you can check out the home page or
the index either the index J or the
index dot HTML pages is the home page
almost always so you can check that code
out and most of those projects are live
as well so you could see the site and
you can see the code behind it
Alexander says I like to know what the
images from Austria are about the hills
look alive okay cool yeah the images
from Austria let's zoom in on this so I
wish I had a higher resolution right now
but I guess this'll work the images from
Austria are of our campus and Austria so
we have two campuses for this University
one here in the United States in
Steubenville Ohio this is the main
campus it's where the school was was
founded then we also have a campus in
Austria and students can go over for is
either a semester or a year I can't
remember which and live and study in
Austria and the program set up in such a
way that basically every weekend you
have enough time to go and travel to
different places in Europe so it's it's
in a small town called gamma in Austria
and it's in an old monastery I think
they called the cart ousa
and okay so it needs to submit my wife's
in the live chat and she corrected me
and said it is a semester so hay bag
yeah so I've never been over there I
really wanted to go over there but
there's really no need for a web
developer to go to the Austria campus I
don't think they'll send me over there
any time soon but the students get to
see a lot of awesome things over in
Europe so it's a good time and in our
professors go over there
so the professors that teach here on
this campus will take you know some time
go over there and teach and then come
back so and you can see the sceneries
beautiful right I mean I don't know it
looks cool I've never been over to
Europe I've never even been out of my
own country so that just kind of
fascinates me but that's kind of a cool
program a lot of students are interested
in it so we kind of like to feature
pictures of this because it's just so
beautiful over there
it's kind of a big selling point for
students who want to come to school here
because not only when they come to
school here and get an education but
they also get a chance to go over to
Europe and travel at the same time so
prospective students really like that
okay so Alexander is actually from
Austria okay cool
oh yeah well like I said I haven't been
over there but from what I've seen of
what the students do over there it's a
very beautiful country so I'd love to
visit sometime alright let's see
Harshad says any good admin dashboard
themes that can pair up well with
material UI and next similar to admin
LTE I could I really thought that I saw
something but this was probably like a
year or so ago so I don't remember what
what it was but I'm pretty sure there
are some material design style admin
dashboard themes out there so I'm really
sorry I just I have no idea where I saw
it but a pretty sure they exist michael
creo says real worms have more protein
but I wouldn't eat them either yeah
actually I don't know if I otherwise
would say this on youtube for everybody
but I did actually eat a real worm once
it was I was really I think I was maybe
an early teenager so maybe like 13 or
something and one of my older cousins
told me to do it kind of like dared me
to do it and I did it so it wasn't that
tasty though so I haven't done it since
the the neon gummy worms are way better
our should said should I do free code
camp I literally never open the site
hard [ __ ]
I mean I think it's cool to do the
exercises sometime I just do a free code
camp like algorithm challenge in the
morning just to get my brain working but
I kind of think you're you're probably
advanced enough that you could just fly
through the backend section of it I know
your back-end person there may be some
stuff in the front-end that may be
helpful to you since you don't have as
much experience with front-end but the
first part of it is is pretty I mean
it's for absolute beginners so I think
the first percent part of it would be
really easy for you but there definitely
is some cool stuff in there so you may
want to check it out and maybe just skip
ahead to some of the harder stuff
Oh tease I asked what my github account
name was let me see
github you think I would know already
what my own github thing was I'll just
I'll paste the link in oh okay it's
Jesse or waggle I kind of thought it
with that okay so there's mine and then
the other one that has I think all
everything that we were going on this
channel is this one there we go
Michael Chris's your wife is keeping
track of you on here my life is actually
learning to code so she's doing free
code camp and Flatiron school and she's
involved with moms can code so she's
learning all kind of coding stuff so
that's probably why she's watching me
and sometimes she has the kids watch me
and they like yell at me thinking that I
could hear them on youtubes anyway it's
cool it that she watches she's probably
starting to get good enough that she can
understand what we're doing she's
actually ahead of me she has more points
than me on free code camp now
okay John I had some more advice about
how to handle the the Rose here
okay so said I might have to put an item
flex column in a flex row inside a flex
row flex container alright if I had all
that in then I may definitely switch
over to materialise if that will fix the
problem because that will be a lot a lot
to add into the mark-up our harshad says
most of the free templates out there a
bootstrap and jquery heavy yeah for sure
harsh ed was asking earlier about a an
admin panel kind of template or theme
that would would match up with material
UI yeah that's true you definitely don't
want to go with one of those if you
don't react yeah I don't know there's
got to be something out there with with
react that's that's going to be at least
some sort of boilerplate to help you get
started I wish I knew something offhand
I could tell you about but if I come
across something soon maybe I'll mention
it in an upcoming live chat then Michael
crow says there's there's no way that
that's you in that picture T Zac said
the Lynx didn't work that I just paste
it in you know for some reason the links
aren't working right when I first paste
them in you could probably just copy and
paste in their browser and it might work
like that
but it's something about the YouTube
redirects that is messing these up when
I paste them in the live chat so anyway
so that those URLs will work but the
link itself may not work if you click on
it in the live chat
what was Michael saying there's no way
that's me in the picture this is me yeah
that's me so my man Brian Sizemore took
that picture of me right outside my
building obviously it was not recently
because there's no snow everywhere but
that was like two and a half years ago
that's me Johnny Anson said not a little
markup once you go smaller components
out of this large per minute yeah you're
right if I just put it in separate
components it won't look that big you
just spread it out it'll look smaller
right it's all right I'll have to think
about it okay all right cool I've gotten
to the end of the live chat so I think
I'm gonna wrap things up now and eat
some more gummy worms I'm going to check
the kitchen and see if there's coffee
coffee and gummy worms that's a good
combo right our hard [ __ ] says why do
that extra work I know her [ __ ] is hard
[ __ ] you I I'm probably gonna end up
going with materialise so don't I would
you worry about it you've made a very
good case for using materialize and I
kind of wanted to do it anyway but like
I said a part of me really wanted to
just see like how hard would it be to
make this work so we figure it out we've
got it working to a point so maybe we'll
switch over you already did the work to
figure out how the hell that would work
and react so really I just need to copy
what you had done in the bulletin
project but so that that's likely going
to happen all right anyway thank you so
much for for watching and for all the
help and the live chat and had a lot of
good questions and a lot of good answers
from you all as well and if you haven't
already check out my
and watch the video that I posted and I
don't have ads or anything I don't get
any money for that but it may help some
of you out if you ever need help with
getting some motivation oh okay
Brook said remember to do a git push all
right
let's tease exes I can't log into github
because I have a new phone number and
they're sending verification numbers to
my old phone can you help me um you may
want to contact github support I'm not
sure yeah I'm not sure if if you can
change that without being able to log in
yeah so I'll contact the support I mean
you should be able to see my repos
without having to log in that's that's
not a problem but if you actually want
to start like you know forking them to
your own your own account you will need
to be able to log in but yeah your
fastest way or your surest way to fix
that resolve that is I think just
contacting github support all right all
right let me get push right now so I
don't forget like I normally do get
status and we're gonna say
they got it recently there I'm just
gonna move it at that I know we added a
bunch more cards but I really didn't do
that much that was new we just kind of
duplicated what was already there
the only kind of new thing we did was
had that gutter we didn't fix the image
thing but I'll leave it off for now
No hey she won she must be skates what
am I not escaping
there we go I was that I knew that that
was hiding in there someone and I forgot
about it all right that was that little
end of that masonry component they got
left in there all right looks good going
through our tests
nice okay there we go all the latest is
now on github okay great all right so
I'm going to go for real this time
thanks again for watching and have a
great weekend I will be back on Monday
all right so see y'all then